welcome to the EZ Eric Easter egg hunt
2011 easy Easter in the house so this
year the 2011 easy Easter egg hunt is
gonna be a little different this year
I've got a head cam I don't wear this on
my head while I hunt so I can be
hands-free while I'm hunting snows a
honey badger doesn't care
honey badger doesn't care if he has a
camera in his forehead or not he doesn't
care these are goggle about to commence
yes here we go gobo
we'll be egg hunt I got this many eggs I
have a feeling that I'm down I'm down a
few eggs this year man
small camp logic kidding me poses with
your projects immigrants I'm bout tapped
out on the Easter Egg hiding locations
like she can't find anymore I don't know
where it's all I got
feel like I'm not gonna win this year
last year I claimed victory
well there we go
easy strike hide over except who's gonna
be the winner of the most eggs who's
gonna be the biggest loser with a camera
on their head me me